الذي يعد واحدًا من أغنى الأشخاص
في العالم وقد تم
تحقيق ثروته في جيل واحد ، فهو
دائمًا يفكر دائمًا في
التفكير في المستقبل ليس فقط في
العلامات التجارية الشهيرة التي يمتلكها
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كانت استثنائية حقًا لأنها كانت
تمنحني دائمًا حس العمل وعندما
وصلت إلى العمل معه بعد
ثلاث سنوات ،
أخبرني الرجل الذي أعتقد
أنك قادر على إدارة العمل ، لذلك
دعونا نفعل ذلك
[موسيقى] ،
شكرًا لك
في
يضيف التسعينيات معرف
مجموعة فاخرة ، وفي ذلك الوقت تعرضت
لانتقادات شديدة بسبب ذلك
، أتذكر أن الأشخاص الذين أخبروني أنه ليس من
المنطقي تجميع العديد من العلامات التجارية
[الموسيقى]
الأجنبية
[الموسيقى
] مع شركائنا بمعايير واحدة
هي الأفضل  الجودة والمنتج الأكثر
نخبوية في كل سطر
نبيعه في جميع أنحاء العالم
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
لقد كانت  النجاح  إنه
نجاح معترف به
[موسيقى]